ein falscher knopfdruck und roboter
bitburg würde die ganzen neuen stihl
kettensägen kaputt machen
der schichtleiter lässt lehrling will
groß deshalb nicht aus den augen
aber roche ist kein anfänger mehr hat
schon zwei jahre ausbildung hinter sich
in der lehrlingswerkstatt schneidet er
zusammen mit anderen bolzen auf den
mikrometer genau zu ich arbeite gerne
mit meinen händen und als ich gehört
habe was man in der ausbildung lernen
kann dachte ich das ist genau das
richtige um mich beispiel voran zu
bringen
also habe ich mich beworben und war
einer der wenigen der es geschafft hat
vier jahre lang unterrichtet ihn sein
ausbildungsleiter thomas kühne am
schluss ist groß mechatroniker ein in
deutschland etablierter beruf die
mischung aus mechaniker elektriker und
programmierer ist in den usa gerade erst
im kommen
die bolzen hat will roche in diesem
roboterarm verbaut
little bird heißt er und wer ihn
konstruieren kann ist fit für den
modernen produktionsbetrieb diesen teil
der praktischen ausbildung hat sich
thomas kühne aus deutschland abgeschaut
und das gefühl der leere aber schönes
programm hat trotzdem ein problem
geeignete lehrlinge finden damit sie
wenigstens ein paar technische
vorkenntnisse mitbringen
kommen sie oft vom militär und sind bis
zu 40 jahre alt außerdem hat
industriearbeit sogenannte blue collar
arbeit keinen sonderlich guten ruf jetzt
versteht man man hat zu wenig fachkräfte
man braucht diese kombination von
theorie und praxis diese neuen dualen
system in deutschland und europa gibt
vor allem für den theorie teil muss
thomas kühne kreativ sein und alle
möglichkeiten in virginia beach ausloten
die stadt ist außerhalb der region vor
allem für eines bekannt
den offiziellen längsten freizeit strand
der welt mit einer fünf kilometer langen
strandpromenade am atlantischen ozean
jenseits der touristen und hotels findet
stil hier aber auch das notwendige
theoretische know how um den praxisteil
der ausbildung zu ergänzen
vier abende die woche muss rasch in die
örtliche berufsschule
dort besuchte er die kurse die am besten
zu seiner lehre passen und grundlagen
liefern wie zum beispiel physik für
ingenieure ist der einzige in der klasse
der das stil programm mitmacht die
meisten hier bekommen nur die reinen
theorie mit auf den weg der lehrling hat
also den wohl anstrengendsten
tagesablauf hier aber müdigkeit lässt
der 32 jährige nicht gelten schließlich
stand er früher noch beispiel am
fließband das hier ist besser ich habe
schon immer versucht in diesem bereich
einen abschluss zu machen
ich wusste also irgendwas klappt schon
aber dass ich so tief in die materie
einsteigen würde
es ist wirklich was anderes und ich bin
auch ein wenig stolz darauf für die
lehrlinge lohnt sich die ausbildung also
aber was ist mit der firma selbst
manager siemens kommt oft in die
produktion er will die
personalentwicklung verbessern und holt
sich feedback von den mitarbeitern
die usa sind der wichtigste markt für
das deutsche unternehmen außerhalb
europas in virginia beach produziert
stil werkzeuge mit einem jahresumsatz
von rund 760 millionen euro
jens weiß dass die käufer nur bereit
sind die vergleichsweise hohen preise
für die produkte zu bezahlen wenn die
qualität stimmt
deshalb glaubt er dass sich das
lehrprogramm auszahlt es ist eine
investition eine investition in die
zukunft
nicht nur für sechs monate sondern für
sechs jahre dann wird es wirklich einen
unterschied machen bei der
produktqualität und diesen unterschied
werden auch die kunden erkennen
made in germany steht zwar trotzdem
nicht auf den kettensägen von virginia
beach aber zukünftige fachkräfte wie
will roche sollen dafür sorgen dass sie
wenigstens so segen wie die aus
deutschland